dis moi mon petit bonhomme si tu n'as
pas si tu n'as pas ton ton diplôme si
t'as pas de bons résultats scolaires un
caisse
toi non ça vous dit quelque chose cette
phrase vous avez déjà entendu
peut-être même que c'est vous qui l'avez
dit un jour parce que moi cette phrase
je l' ai entendu un paquet de fois
qu'est-ce qu'on va bien pouvoir faire de
toi et oui vous avez devant vous ce
qu'on nomme dans le jargon scolaire un
cancre un cancre c'est un mauvais élève
bien sûr alors si vous étiez plutôt bon
élève
laissez-moi vous mets dans ma peau
pendant un petit instant quant à ceux
qui savent déjà ce que c'est je suis
désolé j'ai devoir vous remémorer
quelques mauvais souvenirs
alors un camp que la première chose déjà
c'est que vous êtes plutôt au fond de la
classe
alors je sais ça fait assez cliché mais
en tout cas pour ma part c'était c'était
le cas la deuxième chose qu'on peut dire
c'est que un camp qu'il subit fortement
le regard des autres alors tout le monde
subit le regard des autres mais pour le
camp car c'est quelque chose d'assez
permanent mais surtout je me souviens
d'un mot qui a commencé à renter mon
quotidien et ce mot c'est impossible
mais oui si pour un bon élève tout
devient possible pour un mauvais abers
plus rien ne le deuxième est votre homme
du possible fond comme neige au soleil
alors la question c'est qu'est ce que je
fais ici devant vous ou plutôt comment
on passe d'un statut de cancre à celui
d'un réalisateur d'un producteur et d'un
chef d'entreprise
comment est ce possible eh bien je vais
vous raconter ce qu'il fut pour moi un
long processus dont j'ai pris conscience
il n'y a que très peu de temps et vous
montrer comment ce processus m'a permis
de déplacer
la frontière de l'impossible jusqu'à
celle du possible mais à rome vous
raconter de vous parler ce processus
j'aimerais revenir sur le cancre un
instant je vous ai dit vous savez au
début je vous ai dit si tu n'as pas ton
diplôme si tu n'as pas de bons résultats
scolaires
tu ne pourras pas faire c'est là que
j'ai compris qu'il y avait on va dire
une sorte de mécanisme est récurrent
dans notre société et ce mécanisme on
peut le résumer en trois mots en fait
trois verbes pour être exact avoir faire
et être ce qu'on était en train de
m'enseigner c'est que pour faire quelque
chose il fallait le métier que je
voulais en fait il fallait avant avoir
de bons résultats à voir un exploit et
on voit bien que d'ailleurs si je
reviens là dessus vous voyez bien que
c'est la même chose pour vous songez si
vous êtes jamais dit si seulement
j'avais un peu de temps
si j'avais un peu d'argent si j'avais
des contacts
si j'avais cette formation enfin je
pourrai enfin faire le métier de ma vie
écrire un livre créé ma société et enfin
je pourrais être la chose qu'on nomme
heureux satisfaite en paix ce mécanisme
nous le subissons depuis notre plus
tendre enfance jusqu'à ce que nous
soyons adultes avoir faire pour enfin
être
or quand vous êtes quelqu'un comme moi
que vous ne pouvez nier avoir ni faire
mais oui statut de cancre
qu'est ce qui vous reste mais il vous
reste plus qu'un seul verbe et c'est le
verbe être et voilà comment avec ce
verbe être en partant de ce verbe être
en retournant ce mécanisme de la voir
faire être en être vert à voir et bien
inconsciemment j'ai détruit la barrière
n'est impossible et je vais vous donner
trois exemples concrets
le premier c'est lorsque j'ai voulu
faire mon métier
moi je voulais être réalisateur c'est ça
que je voulais ferme mais c'était
impossible
souvenez-vous pas de compétence pas de
formation pas de diplôme alors j'ai fait
comme si et seulement comme si j'étais
déjà réalisateur en partant de cet état
d'être si je puis dire
eh bien j'ai commencé à m'enfermer dans
ma chambre et fabriquer des films ou
alors ce fut pas du tout facile je me
rappelle d'ailleurs si je m'étais filmé
à cette époque
vous avez vu les phases par lesquelles
je suis passé ben je pense qu'on me
prenne pour un fou
moi non mais ce qu'on peut dire c'est
que je me rappelle de chaque instant à
chaque fois j'étais face à des logiciels
de l'animation en train de cliquer un
parent sur les sur les boutons pour
savoir ce que ça faisait je me souviens
de chaque période de doutes de chaque
période de colère contre moi mais
pourquoi tu n'y arrives pas pourquoi je
me souviens aussi surtout de chacune de
mes victoires et au final j'ai envoyé
mon travail à des divers producteurs
parisiens dont j'allais trouver
l'adresse sur internet quelques jours
après je recevais des dizaines de coups
de téléphone de ses producteurs qui
voulaient me rencontrer
moi j'ai été stupéfait un an plus tard
on me proposait d'avoir le poste de
réalisateur pour de vrai j'ai fait de
série animée diffusée sur la télé que
des millions de gens en vue je n'avais
toujours pas diplôme toujours pas
d'expérience si ce n'est celle que je
m'étais moi même forgé alors vous
comprenez bien que si j'avais attendu
d'avoir un diplôme ou quoique ce soit
d'autre
mais jamais je ne serai revenu des
réalisateurs c'était impossible
mon deuxième exemple est un peu plus
tard lorsque un ami à moi est venu me
dire à écouter rvc c'est quand même
assez astucieux ce que tu as créé je
pense qu'il existe des commissions dead
qui pourrait t'aider à financer ces
techniques super ravie donc je fais je
fais un dossier avec une amie qui est
d'ailleurs présente dans la salle et
nous l'envoyons à cette commission
quelques mois plus tard je reçois la
réponse j'ouvre le courrier fébrilement
cher monsieur
nous avons bien reçu votre dossier un
comité d'experts s'est réuni et a
délibéré malheureusement il a décrété
que vos techniques ne permettait pas de
faire de l'animation de qualité sur
grand écran en 35 mm ce qu'ignoraient
pourtant cette commission c'est qu'entre
temps j'avais réalisé le film
d'ouverture du festival international de
l'animation précisément avec ses
technologies en 35 mm alors si j'avais
attendu d'avoir ces systèmes dead mais
en fait la vérité c'est que jamais
j'aurais pu fermer technique jamais
j'aurais fais mes filles c'était
impossible
l'an dernier raison c'est lorsque j'ai
voulu créer ma société et je voulais
faire une société pour faire des films
de genre un peu nouveau pour l'as qu'on
appelle la génération digitale
alors je me souviens qu'on a voulu lever
des fonds avec mes deux associés et je
me souviens de cette personne qu'on a vu
à un moment donné qui m'a dit d'un ton
un peu sarcastique
cher monsieur trouille et écouter ça
fait 25 ans je suis dans le domaine de
l'investissement dans l'audiovisuel eh
bien je suis au regret de vous dire que
vous l'avez jamais un euro avec votre
projet six mois plus tard on enlevait
plus que ce qu'on avait imaginé d'abord
on a fait une levée de fonds à 500 mille
euros en amorçage et beaucoup plus par
la suite
alors si j'avais attendu que ce monsieur
me donne l'aval
mais effectivement jamais j'aurais pu
créer ma société
c'était impossible alors tout ce que je
vous dis là c'est pas en claquant des
doigts que les faits ça a été un combat
de tous les jours mais au final j'ai
compris que l'on pouvait sclérosé et
tous fait un talent en partant de la
voir quand on pouvait l'épanouir en
partant de l'être la créativité la
gestion des émotions là l'état d'esprit
autant d'outils qui permettent en qui
peuvent vont me dire à partir de lettres
qui peuvent se développer
seulement à partir de ce buzz de ce
postulat aujourd'hui j'ai fondé forge
animations avec mes deux associés sur
cette idée que les tic était un moteur
de développement extrêmement puissant
que la collaboration allait plus
d'avenir que la compétition bien que ces
idées avancent de plus en plus et
gagnent du terrain
aujourd'hui et bien encore malgré tout
ce que j'ai fait j'entends des personnes
me dire que
ces utopies que c'est tout simplement
impossible
alors peut-être que ces gens en réseau
peut-être que c'est impossible mais ce
que j'ai compris c'est que si on
attendait d'avoir les moyens de ce qu'on
voulait être mais la vérité c'est que
rien ne serait possible
alors moi ici je suis pas ici pour vous
convaincre absolument qu être dans une
société on nous enseigne la voir et la
solution face à l'impossible je suis ici
juste parce que je nourris l'espoir que
peut-être après ce que je vous ai dit
quand vous allez voir un enfant vous
n'allez pas lui dire alors qu'est ce que
tu veux faire plus tard
mais plutôt qu'est ce que tu veux être
plus tard parce que comme vous avez pu
constater quelquefois inverse peut faire
toute la différence
merci